bonsoir bonjour importe où vous êtes sur
cette planète la barbacane payer sa
tournée ce week-end avec la copie 19.2
tournée générale le rendez-vous existe
depuis cinq ans mais cette année il a dû
se renouveler en créant des apéros
concerts en temps normal orco vide dans
les villes de notre territoire à la
rencontre des gens dans un format qui
est gratuit qui est à l'heure de
l'apéritif et où on peut découvrir de
jeunes artistes émergents
dans un rapport un peu différent
puisqu'on est dans cette convivialité
autour d'une table
trois soirées de concerts en direct de
la salle installées à ben trois artistes
différents mais un point commun celui de
continuer à faire vivre la culture c'est
du spectacle vivant en théorie donc on a
l'habitude d'avoir les gens après voici
un nouveau format donc on n'a pas les
mêmes attentes et et on essaiera de
faire ce qu'on aime et le faire avec
autant de plaisir que quand les gens
sont là physiquement avec nous on a
choisi vraiment de faire une formule
intimiste pour vraiment avoir
l'impression de pouvoir faire comme si
on est à la maison rentrer chez les gens
pour la salle c'est apéro concert était
aussi le moyen de valoriser les équipes
de l'ombre celles qui permettent un
spectacle de se tenir
et pour ceux qui seraient passés à côté
les soirées sont à retrouver sur les
pages facebook et youtube de la
barbacane